I'm curious how did you decide on the
way to sort of recap the first movie at
the beginning dude because there's a
little bit of a recap did you ever
debate not having that or were you sort
of like people see a lot of movies let's
remind them yeah I think it was um it
was in post it was in post-production uh
where we wanted to make sure that even
if you didn't see the first one you can
understand where you're coming from and
we we like the idea of of the old TV
shows like playing it like uh The Odd
Couple type of a buffet or the A-Team or
it sort of it felt like
you know we're just catching up in case
you missed it you know so that was how
we made that decision speaking of post
I'm I'm fascinated by the editing
process because it's where it all comes
together what did you learn from like
early test screenings or friends and
family screenings that actually impacted
the film
um we learned in the first time we put
it in front of an audience
um we learned that people really love
the movie and um it was amazing to sit
in an audience and watch people laugh
and enjoy the film and everyone loved
Adam and Jen
um and you know we we get feedback on
things in terms of like pacing or
certain jokes that we were testing and
they they worked um we watched the
audience reaction so if we there's a
joke and there's no laughter we we have
one of 35 alts that we put in um and
that's basically what we did I think
Adam and Jennifer together are they're
very good their chemistry is what makes
these movies
um can you sort of talk about what it's
like on set with
um how much is it uh the script how much
is it them as you said coming up with
alts for a lot of scenes well a lot of
the script is designed for them written
for them but they're also putting a lot
of they're both producers they're both
writers and they put a lot of their own
um voice uh into the script so
um by the time we get to set
they've already really processed and
worked out a lot of The Kinks so a lot
of the Improv and the the ideas that
they have were already put into the into
the the scene
um then when we would get this to to set
uh they would be able to play off you
would get what was on the page and then
they would add to it and they'd play off
and they're so great play off for each
other um and they're so fun together but
we had a we had a group of people who
were on set writing auth and we would
have all these all jokes that we would
just try
um and and we got some killers in there
which which are in the movie and um it's
fun I definitely have to ask you there's
no spoilers but the how did you decide
on the ending because it's a little bit
of a I don't look what's the right word
Cliffhanger yeah I mean we love the idea
of doing a cliffhanger
um yeah it was just that was uh was that
always like in the script from the very
beginning it was in a version of the
script but it was also actually now that
I think of it we were actually shooting
at different we were planning on
shooting at different scene for the
ending but because of kovid the the
giant like the thing that we needed for
that scene didn't get there in time so
we had to come up with a different idea
so I I remember pitching this to Adam
um this idea and then we just kind of
did a pass of this the scene and it was
fun it was a it was a fun way to add it
and it definitely makes you you know
makes the audience like wonder what's
happening next you know well the the
first film was incredibly successful for
Netflix and clearly I'm sure if this is
successful uh it wouldn't shock me if
they just Netflix decided maybe we want
one more I say let's do 10 more yeah oh
I want to definitely ask about the
wedding dance and filming that sequence
because it's a huge number there's
amazing costumes and but the real thing
is that I read and could be wrong that
you did not show Adam and Jennifer that
dance until they got on set correct
because I wanted them to feel like the
characters in in the movie
um uh mahina and avishai were the most
incredible choreographers we wanted to
make sure that if we were doing a
wedding and a um an Indian wedding we
had a Bollywood giant Bollywood dance
and we got the greatest
team of dancers choreographers uh it was
so fun to do that
um and we uh we had uh our composers
compose an incredible original song that
we worked on for a long time and um yeah
we just I didn't want Adam and Jen to
know what was going to happen during the
dance and they just were were wingy in
their character they went method
um one so when people watch they should
be watching their faces oh yeah uh I
definitely want to touch on JJ Perry
who's your second unit director and
obviously I'm I believe he helped with
the or did the Eiffel Tower sequence can
you sort of talk about that sequence
because it's a big big stunt for this
movie huge so JJ buso JJ
um uh JJ did the Eiffel Tower sequence
he did a lot of the fight sequences in
there Spiro uh did the car chase the van
Chase sequence um which is out at an
incredible team of of stunts and second
unit directors JJ JJ's in not only a
great second unit director he's an
incredible directory day shift for for
uh for Netflix did it did a great job
such an incredible energy spirit so fun
to be around and really protected
everybody made sure everyone was safe
but we had a really fun time of course I
like asking directors do you already
know what you're thinking about uh for
doing next right now I'm writing
something uh for I started a company
called American High where I bought out
of high school to make High School films
um wait what in other state New York
wait until start again
um I I always love High School movies
like The John all the John Hughes movies
and
um nobody was making them so about five
years ago I bought abandoned High School
in Upstate New York and started a
company called American high and we just
make high school movies we did Big Time
adolescence with Pete Davidson we did uh
the binge with it's Fallen Plan B with
KU Verma who's who's in here
um and yeah so I'm working on another uh
another uh high school movie that we're
gonna shoot um in in April I have to go
but I just can't believe you own a high
school I do it was it called American
High that's crazy come visit
um congrats hope it's a huge hit for you
I gotta go